her head rocks back and i'm like g g
g g nah g
mothers g my g james
g i was screaming mothers mothers
mothers i don't forget i was like
smiles on our faces evidence as to why
you might notice anything new anything
different guys
yeah boy for the audio listeners
we finally got ourselves that studio
we've been talking about
um as you can see oh no not as you can
see all your listeners
just switched to youtube so you can see
what we've got we'll see what we're
working with we've
we're working out it's looking sexy yeah
cleared it out
unbelievable and it's only the start as
well as you can see we've got a few of
our favorite things on the shelf
um looking to add to that if you want to
send us stuff
put that in the comments we can go from
there drop us a cheeky dm if you want to
send us a little something something so
gifts are appreciated appreciate and
welcome
there you go i need to grab a monster g
slimy one please
any color will do
oh
that wasn't as finesse as i'd like we
need to get that sorted
um oh yes
calm so
with no further adie asmr
fun fact of the day please sir um fun
fact of the day
so let me give you a let me give you
like a
scenario let's say for example
you were a you were an uber driver
yeah yeah and you had to drive
let's say like three you had a 300 mile
trip for example
or like a very very long trip um but you
were knackered as
as hell and you were naked as hell and
you
and you asked the passenger if you could
please swap
because you're not you're the driver
you're knackered you've got a long-ass
drive
and they said oh i know this is
unethical but i'm
absolutely shattered can you please swap
so the passenger's now driving you're
kipping in the back seat
you wake up you're in a police chase
what do you do
this is not a fact and this is not fun
jesus
you're in a police chase in a police
chase donnie's kipping in the back
no you were keeping in the back oh i'm
the driver you're the driver sorry i've
woken up and we're in a police chase yes
and donnie's doing a madness yes i don't
know what's yeah quiet yes
just pause you there this is actually a
fun fact it happened in 2016.
really yeah
i don't know what i do are the child
locks on
what are you gonna do jump out i would
jump out you wouldn't jump out
of a police chase you wouldn't drop out
the car let's be realistic you would
drive out the car
i believe a high speed chase oh my god
fam i don't know what i do i have to
reason i will have to start from
from the bottom or work our way up i'll
say donnie what's going
on what's happened he's just swerving
that's what woke you up
is he answering my queries is he
answering me trying to get away
all he's trying to do is get away now
you wake up and you're in the middle of
a police chase
now yeah mom i'll scream
i will scream i don't know because i'll
be tempted to choke him from the back
you know what i mean
[Laughter]
some white i would tend to just choke
him but i don't want to i don't want him
to flip the vehicle and kill us all
i really don't know as well didn't it
that is wild
i'm fighting very very wild so tell me
about the true story what happened
i don't know i don't know the end i
don't think the end of the story but
i've known that 2016 2016.
uh uber or taxi driver or whatever was
tired was tired asked asked the
passenger to take over
i'm assuming he said it's a free thing
if you just drop yourself i'm assuming
something
i will find out if if i find out more
information about it
i'll bring up in another episode where
did you find that don't worry about that
all right you've got your sources i've
got my sources um so
i've left you holding on long enough you
want to know happened to my eye
oh my god yeah i forgot about that yes
yes so uh backstory as to why you're
talking about it
so as a backstory i uh i've been saying
to
who had all week that i've messed up my
eye so i've been in and out of hospital
three times this week
um i was just on the phone to the
hospital a minute ago yeah
they booked me in for friday this week
oh wow um
i've been putting drops in my eye um and
i
intentionally didn't tell fuhad what
happened
um so we could discuss it on here but um
bro i nearly went blind oh god so
i was um playing with enzo
we were rolling around on the floor uh
enzo was a baby by the way
um so we were rolling around on the
floor all gone no i'm just saying the
clarification just
ends there's a baby because they might
be thinking he's a grown man yeah yeah
and i'm just ramping on the floor with
some grown man
so um me and ezra was roaring around on
the floor playing playing
just bare laugh laugh giggle giggles and
he got carried away
scratched my face scratched my
eyeball scratched my
eyeball i dashed him off
and i was like ah
but like obviously i've never
experienced anything like that before
which i was it left or right right eye
here and um
i've never experienced anything like
that bro so i'm just
thinking i just need to get some water
in my eye
it felt like just something's in my eye
in it so i was like cool cool cool cool
um went to the bathroom i'm splashing my
face with water etc
and um it's still hurting so for ours
it's just going to be a bit sore
gave it 10 minutes 15 minutes 20 minutes
the thing is still sore
i can't open this eye at all if i open
imagine
like imagine you know how it feels to
have an eyelash
in your eye oh my god imagine having
humbles me bro
that's the most humbling experience it
brings you back to if it makes you feel
like
nothing brings you to your knees it
makes you feel it makes you feel like
you're nothing
so um oh it's the worst it's the worst
thing but yeah
imagine that imagine 10 of those in your
eye
jesus so blinking so opening my eye
i had vision opened in my eye
i it the the the friction of obviously
my eyelid on my
like rubbing on my eye was so painful
cause i can't even explain to you
it felt like a glass in my eye it was so
painful every time i would blink
it was [ __ ] agony so i had to keep
this eye closed yeah
but the worst part was i also had to
keep this eye closed
because if i would open this eye yeah
when i blink with this eye
even though this eyes closed it would
move yeah yeah of course and when i'm
looking around with this eye this
eyeball moves
even if it's closed
you can't isolate it i was walking
around blind
blind i had a shower everything nothing
was
i just wanted the steam to rejuvenate me
i mean
i had a shower in the pitch black i
needed something to work yeah but
i found nothing was working so
um i'm petrified now so after about an
hour
eyes leaking because can't open this eye
everything
called uh the hospital and said like et
cetera et cetera et cetera
and they were like you need to go to the
emergency room within the next three
hours i panicked
very panicked i scurried around
and obviously i can't drive i was going
to say how did you get there
i had to bail my mum who was about 20
minutes
away yeah builder and was like get me
please you have to take me to the
hospital so um
she comes slowest driver slowest driver
first thing she comes to pick me up
first thing out of my mouth let me see
it i'm like
mom i can't get in the car
let me see it what are you looking for
bro i was
vexed got got to the hospital sit in the
emergency room obviously they left me
waiting there for hours
so it's becoming unbearable yeah it's
physically unbearable yeah
so um we're in there
waiting wait and wait in and it's what
10 p.m
now 11 p.m eye is killing me and i'm
thinking
please someone do something to sort this
out please someone do something to sort
this out
bro in my time of need
the doctor shouts me and he's like
from foreign donny he looked knackered
you know one um like grey's anatomy
yeah and scrubs when they've been doing
the night shifts
that's what my man looked like oh god so
he's like my phone comes in
a man he opens the door yeah and picture
this he opens the door
and my man is scratching his balls in
his scrub
scratching his balls he's got like tired
stubble
you know when you usually shave every
day but you know when like he must have
forgot to shave today or he's been
working
24 straight yeah yeah next double
face double and he's like mr james mr
james and i was like not him [ __ ] sake
i go into his room and he just walks off
i go into his room he just walks off
round the back like there's another
because he's you go in from the
emergency room but at the back of the
office
leads into just like a hallway okay so
he just walks up into the hallway and
i'm like
following him kind of here but like
timidly yeah thinking am i supposed to
follow you
he hasn't told me to do anything yeah
and he just starts chin wagging with
another doctor for like two three
minutes
and i'm like big man what's what is
going on yeah so i'm standing there
waiting and he turns around and he looks
at me like what are you doing and he go
he's like go now go sit down i'll
sit down and i'm like all right gee like
cool
i sit down told him what happened he's
all right cool cool cool had a quick
look in my eye and he's all right
let's go have a look um on the
you know the actual like optician
machine so where you put your chin on it
and then it like zooms in there firm he
takes me in there
sits me down and he's like cool put your
chin on this thing um
and we'll have a look i'm like oh thank
god bro
i sit down put my chin on the ting i'm
just edge up like that
waiting my mind can't turn the ting on
he unplugs it plugs it and he's
the way he's trying to turn it on is how
i would try and turn it on yeah if he
just asked me to turn it yeah yeah
he's twisting things that have nothing
to do with power sourcing he works here
i wanna say have you used this before i
felt in danger he's bad just twisting it
up and down
that's not in danger i was thinking my
eyes never gonna get fixed
he doesn't even know what he's doing oh
i'm like nah brother
and then he's like um he's like all
right
this ain't working and that's what he
said he said this ain't working no
fam he said this ain't working so i'm
just gonna have a look with the
other thing you know the thing that they
put in your ear that's kind of like yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
he looks in one of those okay okay
yeah open my eye wide and he's bare
looking in that thing yeah
and i'm like cool and he's like well
i can't see anything so he just gives me
um he gives me
i'm gonna give you this antibiotic that
you put in your eye it's a cream
it's a cream it's a cream that goes like
on your eyeball and then you have to
just blink it in
it's disgusting so he's like i'm going
to give you this antibiotic cream
mine opens up the ting to make sure the
seal ain't broken because he just drapes
it from any draw
opens up the thing is i think it's
called like
i don't know writing trend or something
like that
that's what he said to you that's what
you said he said to me he's like i think
it's called
write a dream someone pulls the thing
out and he's like yeah writes a drawing
family opens the things i just want to
make sure this one ain't been opened and
i'm thinking what is going
on here this is a hospital because this
is a hospital no wonder he works the
night shift
fam and i'm thinking this is i'm
terrified he hasn't prescribed this for
me nothing he's just dropped he just
opened the draw and hoped it was in
there and hoped he wasn't on
and hope someone hadn't just tampered
with it nah
i was thinking what on what plan like i
think if you to check that has never
been open like
when have you ever opened antibiotics
that have already been opened what's
going on in here
what kind of what kind of [ __ ] show are
you man running no
and so he's like cool it ain't been
opened and he
opens up you know the leaflet that comes
inside to read he read it
and he's like i think it's three times a
day and he's like yeah three times a day
so you want to use it three times a day
he's reading it and i'm like oh my god
he's
he's never done this before he's never
experienced this before what am i going
to do this is so uncomfortable
fam then so i'm like he was like cool so
he's sending me home
and i'm thinking i know for example this
is an antibiotic
yeah so this isn't going to help me heal
yeah it's a it's
i have to hear about myself and the pain
is so unbearable i'm terrified now
so i'm like to my man i'm like all right
cool and he's going to send me home he's
all right cool
so um uh
take this three times a day et cetera et
cetera
um and you're good to go and it should
prevent the infection and stuff
fam i'm like okay
so am i going home now and he's like
yeah you can go i was thinking
about i don't think this guy understands
the amount of pain i mean i can't live
like this
and um i says to my man so what like i
said
so should i try and keep it closed or
keep it open he said what do you mean
and i was like should i try and
should i be trying to open my eye is
that going to help her heal or should i
be keeping it closed covered like what
and he's like now obviously when you're
putting the cream on it you need to open
it and i was like
big man in general in general as i'm
just living my life
should my eye be open or should it be
closed yeah and man's like
nah nah nah it's gonna be hard to try
and keep it closed all the time
so you should uh try and keep it open
and i was like
cool he said yeah yeah try and keep it
open
um but you want to not look at any
lights or any sunlight
because that would be bad for it and i
was like crazy said than done
continue and he's like and also a lot of
people don't know this there's actually
like invisible dust in the air
yeah don't let any of that dusk in your
eye i could have swung his jaw off
if i could see if i could see i would
have swung him
hey man said keep your eye open but
don't let the invisible dust get in
there because you're [ __ ] if it does
i wanted to ah fam i wanted to sue the
nhs
if i were to call who's your boss man
because you're clearly not qualified
enough to be dealing with me bro it was
a nightmare
do you know what that reminds me of what
remember scrubs remember the janitor
when the jenna always used to try and
get in touch yeah get in touch with
patients and stuff
he was probably like a [ __ ] janitor
he was scratching his balls and be like
just found some scrubs he fell he found
himself threw him on threw him on the
floor
tonight that's why he probably was in
the hallway into chit-chatting to my man
the man was like what are you doing
what are you doing is it does it now
um hey man said what you doing is sit
down
i was so livid um luckily i'm assuming
either he [ __ ] up the charts
or someone like read into it later
because the next morning
the next morning my eye was swollen shut
i physically couldn't open it
had you put the cream on at this point i
put it on once okay so i put it on once
before i went to bed okay
i'm ready to wake up put it on again
found my eye was swollen shut
oh wow and even this eye was swollen
because of the amount of [ __ ] like
irritation i'm getting is affecting this
one this one's getting red and this
one's getting like
irritated because they're just watering
fam
swollen shot and i was thinking i can't
do this i had to obviously bring my boss
and said i can't work cause
yeah i can't do i can't do this and i
was thinking how how long am i gonna
have to live like this
like for the first i woke up in the
morning
i had to put a podcast on on the tv and
just lay there with my eyes closed and
listen
cuz because i can't do anything i
couldn't do anything
and then luckily the doctors rang me the
hospital roamed me
and we're like cool we need you to come
in today and i was thinking praise
jesus christ yeah praise him
fam because i wasn't going to survive
i'm literally
went there went there and then
i'm going to close this window hang on i
don't think it's open
i actually don't think it's open it must
be open though
it must be i actually don't think it is
it better be
we just got that sound briefing i don't
think it is
i honestly don't think it is
it's not it's not open man
interesting at least we know
there's breeze coming through the team
it must be over
it's not safe man
cool i think that's better
i don't know we'll see it only sounds
better because the thing drove away
so what was i um i called you next day
they called me next day i'm thinking
thank god went in there and then
obviously went to the eye department
sat me down
and this noise uh this is probably no
one can hear but there's a really loud
truck outside and it's annoying me um so
when
sat down and this is where i nearly lost
it luckily they saved the day about five
seconds after
yeah went into the eye department
and so i went actually nom so she bills
me she's like cool come in
um and you need to come to the the
outpatients
okay i i outpatients okay sounds like
cool
go to the emergency room obviously i
don't know where anything is in hospital
obviously
i still can't see and obviously because
covered i had to get my mom to
drop me again but because of coverage
you have to go in by yourself you can't
have people with you
so i'm just stumbling around i made it
to the outpatient's bit go to reception
and luckily it was right next to a e and
i'm like cool i'm here
for my appointment for my eye and she
was like oh no you need eye out patience
that's in the eye department that's on
the next thing
and i was like where fam my girls
directions cool so you want to go down
here
take a right then an immediate left
downstairs
take another left and then it's another
left again
down there right and you should be there
fam
i was like and she laughed because she
knew how heinous what she was saying to
me was
she laughed she laughed because she knew
she who's
remembering who can remember that i was
thinking first of all how do you
remember that
and secondly i bet it's not even the way
because you're just saying bare left
rights
and i was like i'm sure i'll find it and
she was like cool fam i was stumbling
bear bumping into people i was thinking
someone put me out my misery because
please i can't live like this
and then um yeah then i finally get
there
they call me into the doctor's office
and i'm thinking please pat on something
yeah
he same thing the chin ting he's got the
machine
is that cool this is the eye department
put your chin on here
and i'm like all right put my chin on
there cozy if i'm thinking yes
finally gonna get sorted yeah man
did the twizzle thing to turn it on he
was bear like
okay and went to press it nothing came
on vampire
turning twizzling knobs and i was
thinking the eye doctor doesn't know how
to use it either
i'm gonna sue i was thinking i'm gonna
sue i'm super i
don't give a [ __ ] anymore i'm assuming
someone because this is [ __ ] bro
yeah
and then luckily he patterned it
put a contact lens in my eye to stop the
the irritation from my eyelid yeah
change the
game as soon as you put that contact
lens in my eye change the
game bro i've never had anything in my
eye so when he was trying to put it in
fam i was yeah
i could imagine i was because i
oh i could never pull contact with my
glasses so i can't believe it
i was edging away he finally put it in
and it was
so uncomfortable for days i had it in i
think i got it on monday
they took it out on friday okay donnie
took it out with tweezers fam
he put tweezers on my eyeball to take it
out it was atrocious
my god it was atrocious did you have to
leave it in for those five days
yeah i didn't take out once okay every
morning i would wake up and it would be
sticky dry i had to just drip drop it
because i was going to say like with
with lenses you have to take them out
before you sleep and put them up yeah
yeah that's what i was asking
i can see why they take him out but he
said nah this one has to stay in because
obviously
as soon as i take it out it's just gonna
start [ __ ] with the cut again
so um my diagnosis was that i had
an abrasion on my cornea and it was um
it was long fam it was a it was a
horrible horrible
horrible week jesus yep
that was my week sorry bro it's cool g
it is what it is you said you had
something for me in it yeah but you know
what i'd say no i don't know yet so
it's on pause it's still on pause you
haven't found out i'd say that i'm found
out so
all right i've got a potential story for
this for the team
but you know i don't know if i'm allowed
to say because it's not really my story
to sell so
as soon as i'm allowed to say it if i'm
allowed to say it you guys will know
per play but it's a juice in that case
do you wanna some trash news of course
bro check this out
there is a um
a law in america
called the ghostbusters ruling this is a
real thing
okay there's a law in america called
i've got another trash news afterwards
there's a law in america called the
ghostbusters ruling right okay where
you are not allowed to sell someone a
house
that's haunted without telling them that
it's haunted
i feel like i've heard of this but
continue so there was a case a few years
ago
where a woman lived in a house and she
was certain that it was haunted
okay then um
she reported to the newspapers
everything just wanted just on his word
so she sold it
donny who buys it
um moves in bless everything she's gone
next door neighbor obviously just
cutting hedges or whatever
pulls up like i'll swear you bought the
the haunted thing yeah
and he's like horny thing okay and then
the neighbor's like yeah yeah like my
god i lived there said that it was
haunted
and he's like nah obviously
superstitious nah
nah what yeah yeah that thing's worth it
obviously
hollered my girl said run me my pee back
he didn't tell me this thing was haunted
she was like
shut up shut up you signed b fam
my man took her to court and the judge
said
brav you can't be said in man haunted
house
yeah and usually you would assume that
like that's shut up like what it's not
haunted
but that's what she tried to say she was
like obviously not wanted like this is a
joke
and she's like well the judge was like
big man well
you thought it was haunted and you told
the papers that you think is haunted
and you told your neighbors that you
think it's haunted
so the fact that you think it was wanted
is enough that you should be disclosing
that information to someone else
before they're gonna buy the house yeah
and then fam she had to give him the
money back
[ __ ] that's the most outrageous law i've
ever heard of in my life [ __ ]
that's the most outrageous i've ever
heard of in my life but i'm thinking now
if i bought the house if it was i was
thinking if i bought the house
if i bought the house and my neighbor
was like yo you that house is haunted
i don't know at what point would i be
like i don't want to live here anymore
do you know what i mean or if i'd ever
get to that point yeah yeah yeah i don't
know what point i'm going to be like
nah run me my people you ever watch um
american horror story
no that looks too scary see
i've seen a couple trailers here and
there it looks too scary it's actually
it's actually very scary i think it's
season one or season two because it's
this is similar cast
each season but each season is a
completely different story topic kind of
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i think it's
season one or season two where
they live in i think it's season one
where they live in a haunted yard yeah
it's season two i think it's season two
they live in hollywood so
as you were saying it was just reminding
me of that bro it's crazy do you want do
you want to know where
another [ __ ] um crazy lawyer in
america yes uh i can't remember what the
law is called
i think it's in summer like mississippi
scientific schools
um there's a law where you're allowed to
take you're allowed to take horses to
school like you're allowed to
arrive it to school on honor yeah
and it's stipulated in the principles
um what's the word i'm looking for in
the principles um
like the stuff you have to do what's the
word i'm looking for
roles like the roles and regular rules
the roles you have to do
responsibility responsibilities
it's part of the principal's
responsibilities that
if someone rocks up in a horse or on a
horse
they have to feed it clean it and look
after it the principal the principal has
to do it but obviously
that role isn't broadcasted it's not an
advertisement yeah yeah a couple of
students found out and on the last day
five of them rolled up in horses he had
to look after him that's wild
and it's it's an actual i can't remember
which it's in america but i can't
remember which state
that is there's an actual like child
yeah now cuz
yeah as the thing with law is like when
it's such a stupid law yeah like at what
point
do you what point are you ever just
allowed to refuse the law
do you know that if i'm a principal yeah
yeah and these
[ __ ] are rocking up on horses to
try and tell me to feed it and look
after it all day because it's
the law obviously i'm not i'm never
gonna do it never i'm
never gonna do it you can't send me to
pen for this do you know what i mean
yeah i don't care if it's the look
you're not i'm not going to pay for this
yeah you can't make me
what you're in for i didn't clean a
couple horses because i didn't feed some
dirty horses but i'm not doing it
i'm never gonna do it yeah i'm i'm never
doing it like i can't imagine a
situation where he's like
[ __ ] sake it is the law so he's he
actually does it
that's wild it's a real thing [ __ ]
he's a realtor yeah mum jesus christ
your mom
is weird that is nuts um i've got a
couple
i've got a couple um fan stuff fan stuff
a lot of
a lot of people have followed me
recently to
hmm you told me you banged through all
of them right yeah
you had like a big backlog so you're
good at that that's like
we have different strengths like so i i
i'm
i'm good at i try to be good at like
replying
on the time yeah they send it and i
reply to them yeah but
if it gets more than like five yeah and
they're stacked up and i haven't replied
no one's getting a reply i'm not no
one's gonna reply i can't take
20 30 minutes out of my day it's a lot
this is a lot it's a lot
i love the messages that we get stuff
like that but just understand this a lot
something yeah same for that for the
guys that message
us separately i'm assuming you know that
there are times where
me especially i don't reply straight
away because i'm i'm so busy
um so i reply probably like a week later
for some people
but yeah still send them oh that's
another one because i'll send them
but just send them to the sng page yeah
don't send them one thing did you see i
don't know if you saw one thing
yesterday or the day before send it to
mine send it to the smg page i'm
assuming send it to yours
and turn it as well and to twitter and i
think i've seen it
i was like come on cuz come on guys
that's too much
like we'll see we're gonna see him like
we'll see it guys we're gonna see him
yeah don't worry one of them we will see
you send them to one of them um so yeah
send it to the smg picture because
i don't always know so if someone sends
it to me directly
yeah there's been times where you send
it they've sent it to me directly
i've replied i've then later on or the
next day
check the sng page and it's not it's in
there and sometimes you've replied on
there
now i'm fixed
now i'm fix i know what you mean my time
is precious cause you got yourself
my time is precious you i got time for
people to be getting bare replies just
send it to the smg page please
but still at the same time much
appreciated um yes like we said earlier
just still keep sending them but
ideally please just send it to the sng
because we will reply more time
quicker on there yeah than um our
personals
anyway um i think he sent this to you as
well i'm obviously not
not going to say his name but i'd like
to know what you said so yeah
bro i've been a big follower of you
i've been a big follower of the podcast
and i've seen you give people advice
and i need some i've been with my girl
for four years
last year we broke up and we both
obviously spoke to other people
we have been back together nearly a year
and for some reason i had the
opportunity to look at her snap
as she left her phone open next to me i
was gonna say i was gonna take a stupid
pic or something but i saw that in july
she had a chat open with a guy she spoke
to last year when we were broke up
she cleared the convo but the chat was
still there from the 12th of july
that night i was out with my boys but
there is ev there is no other evidence
but that and they had a conversation and
they had a conversation on that day and
she admits they did
and that's it and she he said
i sent it to james because i wanted two
different opinions to see what you have
so he's asked basically asking he opened
the chat
he saw that he's texting a thing and he
saw that girl's text he's texting a
thing that
he was she was apparently talking to
when they're on break
etc um what should he do like
obviously he she's admitted it yeah yeah
yeah but what
um did you know he said he said his
james do you remember i remember
it yeah i cannot remember what i said
but i haven't changed as a person so i'm
assuming this is what i said
because i know how i feel about it i
basically told him to stop being a beta
yeah
i think in nice words i remember i'm
pretty sure i'm most nice about it but
i'm pretty sure i told my man to just
stop being a [ __ ] like
things like that especially if she's
like yeah yeah we had the chat like
okay cool so your goal was talking to a
guy when you guys were broken up
and either he messaged your girl
or whatever or maybe your girl replied
to one of his snaps or something like
that
doesn't mean that she's out sucking them
off every wednesday
do you know what i mean it just means
that he popped up and
maybe was like hey or looking good or
something she might have been like
thanks
like it could have been such an innocent
thing like and i said
i remember what i said yeah i said at
the end of the day you're never gonna
know
the truth yeah in terms of like
she said to you oh we had a chat it was
innocent
the fact that you're messaging me asking
me what you should do
what do you mean what you should do what
is there to do
the chat's deleted there's nothing you
can do it's done
yeah like the only thing you can do is
choose to believe her and not believe
her
and if you want to be with her i suggest
you choose to believe it yes because
otherwise this thing's going to eat you
it's going to swallow you it's going to
swallow you
whole family so i suggest you just bite
the bullet and move on
come on because this this [ __ ] all you
can do about it yeah yeah yeah but
anyway what did you use it
well this is one of this is one of the
ones where
he sent it to me obviously sent it to
you and probably sent it to the pod
and i didn't reply for a while so i
messaged him saying
uh can i reply on the pod if that's
called etc
and he messaged me this was like this
was over a week later
yeah oh i know it was fun because i
remember this was because
obviously i know when you told me that
you'd gone through that
okay okay i know that that to me sounds
like eight
years ago yeah yeah so he sent this in
september i replied in october
that's how long it was the audacity he
was like bro
the circumstances have changed yeah oh
we've got a re-up but we've got an
update
yeah juicy
my mouth guys she got watered
when i read what i'm about to read
bellowed thumb
i laugh my mouth is salivating sell me
the juice
he bro the circumstances
he said i found out she was googling
some [ __ ] like
why do i fantasize about older men and
does my boss like me more than a friend
she then admitted she had a thing for
her boss
and she's a secretary she was searching
boss
and secretary porn hahaha so yeah we're
taking a break
she's a naughty naughty i my response
was
lol in capital letters sorry to laugh
but you kind of have to laugh now i was
like that's wild and then i said oh did
james reply
he said bro i've been crying
i've been crying i wrote i've been
crying how to read
an older married man's signals this girl
has
this girl was having a whole affair on
google searches
and you said that you you responded
super um methodological
like you do on the podcast i was like i
talked to
i'm gonna talk to you i'm gonna talk
about it on the part and so feel free to
discuss
i'm so intrigued because i know i don't
know what to do
my african-ass mum has cursed her he
told his mom
don't tell him i've got a thing i don't
know what it is
there's certain things that have
happened like throughout my life where
people have told me that they've told
their mum certain things
and i'm like why in god's name would you
tell your mom
why in god's name first of all i don't
tell my mama hardly anything i didn't
tell my mom nothing i just got on my day
nothing mom doesn't need that level of
stress and then what do
what is it what's my mom supposed to do
when i bring the the app back in the
yard
when i don't know my sense and i bring
her back in the yard what am i expecting
my mom to do
oh my gosh she's going to back her up my
mom doesn't need that
mom doesn't need she doesn't need that
but um first of all right cool
that's [ __ ] hilarious it's the most
funny thing secondly
how did he clock what she was searching
that's i don't know that's what i'm not
happy about i don't know he's
he's probably it sounds a little bit too
convenient that in the space of
obviously in the space of two weeks yeah
he's coincidentally
seen her snap conversations because he
was gonna innocently
take a picture take a picture first of
all i know that convos and pictures are
two separate pages
and they take a distinct left or right
swipe
so there's no way you open snap and snap
doesn't once you open slap it doesn't go
to conversation it's going to go
straight to the picture
so we see you guys don't worry
we we we're here for you we're here for
you but you just tell the truth yeah
basically up front with us yeah tell us
what you really know how we know how
these things roll you can't lie to us
you can't like you can't lie to us cause
we know so yeah i know for a fact now
that you evade these dm's you were
snooping
i know for a fact that you were snooping
in your car's phone
that much is clear
that much is [ __ ] clear anyway so
you're a little snoopy snoop cool man
we've all been there we have been there
we've all been there yeah so
you snooped you didn't like what you saw
again like
i gave you the methodical answer there's
nothing you could do about it really so
just hope
to believe your girl right so but in the
same space of the two weeks you've
clocked what she was googling
now the fact
that there's one like obviously
i don't know if you were googling on
your girl's ting and maybe you typed how
and that recent search popped up but
maybe not i don't know i i find that
hard i feel like
school doesn't also necessarily work
like that yeah it does pop up with what
you searched before
but not from like the first word
i'm i'm very intrigued to know whether
he
let's say for example they share a
computer or share a
pc and that's probably how we probably
check the history because if he's
found that on her phone again oh yeah
that's a completely
different story that's a completely
different story that is a completely
different story
so he's found those search just for
context guys if he's found those
searches
on his girl's phone then he's obviously
gone into his girl's phone again gone
into the phone again they've gone into
the browser
got on the search history and that's
that's invasive
yes he's found stuff yeah but if you're
looking for stuff you're always going to
find stuff
that's digging for trouble you're going
to find trouble so
yeah i never i i like sorry to interrupt
i
will never ever give people the get out
of jail free card when they find [ __ ]
yeah if i find out that someone's like
invaded another person's
privacy i don't care what they've found
yeah like your actions are still not
justified you deserve it oh yeah you
like yeah
i i hate when people are like yeah but
like when
people have told like me or us like our
friends in the past where
it's been like oh like obviously my girl
went through my phone and she clocked
this and that
yeah and i'm like what's she doing going
for your phone brother he's like
obviously i know like i've told her
before but at the end of the day she's
got a point because she's found
something
no she hasn't got a point she hasn't got
a point because like
that also leads to believe that like
those times that she's found stuff
are the only time she's ever gone
through your phone and i refuse to
believe that as well
um so yeah because you shouldn't have
been going through a [ __ ] for one for
one for starters
you got your to be fair you got yourself
into this trouble now yeah because if
you didn't go through none of her [ __ ]
ever
and if you just took your goofy pick and
moved on and moved on we wouldn't be in
this mess we've been in the situation
you'll still be in a happy relationship
my boy
you're in a break now you're probably
broken up now no i mean
you're probably single this is the thing
like this is the thing that we spoke
about before like ignorance is bliss
people don't give ignorance it's due i
know because ignorance is bliss like
like i said like
you've now gone and invaded her privacy
and found out that she's got a thing for
her boss she wants to get [ __ ] by her
boss
granted she probably hasn't done
anything she probably hasn't like a lot
of people
just search [ __ ] like a lot of people
fantasize a lot of people have
make up things in their head as well
like she doesn't know whether her boss
likes her
she's fantasizing about her boss liking
her because she thinks her boss likes
her more than a friend
hence her googling boss secretary she's
hoping anyway but yeah she's hoping so
that's why she's trying to live out that
fantasy that's
sexy by the way sex so first of all
first of all but that
it's mad because it's just crazy to
it boils back to when us when i spoke
about um
one of my friend's friends not wanting
to give head anymore
but it always depends on the guy so it's
clear that
she's into some [ __ ] and the boyfriend
has no idea what she's into
she likes this work based hierarchy
thing she does she likes this power
structure she likes the power structure
she likes the autonomy of a man
yeah to be fair to be fair what
he could have done so with this he could
have done something with it so he could
have gone on
if he was feeling frisky frisky good one
if he was really frisky
mama could have done his little snoopy
snoop yeah clock that she was uh
fantasizing about a boston thing like
older men this
uh and then he could have sat down got
his emotions out
and just for all right she's into that
freaky nasty yeah all right cool
she likes that power structure i would
have turned up that night in a suit
tux everything i was told to sit down
sit down fam tie her hair up chopstick
thing
do you want you want that secretary get
your glasses on chopsticks
short skirt fam that would have played
out that entire fantasy for her
entire family that's what she's into i
would have played out that entire thing
but that that
i would have dumped her afterwards but
yeah that sounds good but
there's no way in the hell she won't
know that he's gone through this she's
gone through the phone good shout out
you know what i mean good shout out
good shout out because you can't just
sporadically [ __ ] out he's clearly not
a role play kind of guy
do you know what i mean yeah he's not
he's not and she knows he's not yeah
that's why she's good and [ __ ] oh
i didn't listen yeah because i've
watched my fair share
of boss secretary porn oh and i'm no
one's boss so no one's got anything to
worry about
yeah but um i've watched my fair share
and it's buff
i did not know that yes we're out here
searching for that i've never i've never
thought that was something anyone would
search can you imagine
the boner her boss would have got if he
found out that she was searching for
that
rock diamond cutter
diamond cutter diamond cut if i'm
someone's boss
and i'm just like living in my dice
finding out ways of how she can she can
pat him at all
and she's watching role play porn
based on this thing that we've got i
don't even know we've got this i'm the
wife
i'm i'm oblivious to this oh and then
she comes in next day button blouse
undone
just cleavage shut out skirt here
tights heels i'm sending hatred on
holiday
because i'm banging you i'm sending the
whole hr department
on holly bobs because we're [ __ ]
that's sexy that is sexy that's sexy
that's too sexy it's a shame though
because you snooped for a phone and now
you're sitting
for a phone then again it's not too late
you said you're taking a break kind of
thing maybe he can get back in contact
because now she knows that he snooped
yeah so maybe if he's feeling frisky
he can hold her back and be like listen
clearly you're into a certain type of
sex that you weren't getting from me
what did we say did we give this thing a
try oh
i got i got my belt i got some handcuffs
is this so what do you want i've got a
desk
we could do what it is would you want to
do what are you saying
you never know she could like yuck go
away or she could be like
come [ __ ] me now and so honestly you've
got to take mom
you've got nothing to lose it's like
you're risking literally got nice you
guys aren't even together anymore but um
that's sexy granted i wouldn't want i
wouldn't want to know that my girl was
doing that
fantasizing though no one wants to hear
that girls fantasizing about next man
nope that's tough that's very tough also
what answer did she want from google
anyway
true true but you never know this is
everything everything's on google you
never know
like the thing at the end of the day you
never know what someone else is
searching or what someone else has put
on the internet unless you search for it
yeah but like i mean
i'm saying like if she typed in like how
do i know if my boss like oh does
does my like boss like me more than a
friend or whatever what do you want to
say i don't know yeah he does i don't
know what i don't know maybe he would
have popped up with like
key facts to know that you're both yeah
key signs or like eye contact
i don't know man it's [ __ ] is
criminal all over again that episode
that is
that is criminal all over again all over
that's a risky thing as well it is a
very she can't stick it on him
because he could suck it on the spot on
the spot and if he's
thinking he's definitely not sticking it
on her because he has no idea if she's
doing it or not
oh that's that's tension i love sexual
you see where i lick my lips
i love sexual tension work place sexual
tension tension
that's tension that's too much that's
too much
nice i feel like everyone's had a bit of
a fair share of work place sexual
tension obviously depending on probably
almost everyone interested we spoke
about this before but it's like one of
the things is like you spend
you spend most of your time at work i
work of course and the people who are
around at work like
it's it's it's common knowledge there's
always people beating at work
always always always yeah
shadow of a doubt yeah this is
this it's mad it's but it's mad
so what i've got to go ahead you got
whilst we're having all this yeah i've
got to go
this is a juicy app so um
as i said to you earlier um i've got a
story it's not
concerning me well it is concerning me
but i'm not the main party but i had to
get
permission first so um
i was chilling at home this is obviously
bella
okay cool i knew it was better yeah
okay so chillin at home this was it was
the day you called me
where i was having a roast it was a
monday because i had a roast on a monday
for some reason because i live my own
life and i make my own rules i don't
have time on a sunday
i had it on a monday i knew you had
called me and i was
i think i was just about to come off the
phone and bella was eating as well
is this where you i was hearing bear it
was
last week monday it's not the monday
gone just the one before that i remember
because i was like
driving yeah yeah so it was that monday
we were talking wait i can't we're
talking about but yeah i came off the
phone
and and this one i think she had just
come back from holiday or sign i can't
remember yeah
so we were chillin chillin chillin eatin
and prior to her going on holiday
she said she had like a a kind of a pain
in her stomach
just about here i was like okay you
should just probably go get a check edc
yeah yeah um and then when i completely
forgotten about that pain thing
and then after um when she came back
from holiday we were chilling e in the
roast
and then she randomly i saw her look
down at the stomach thing again i was
like
i didn't say anything i was just like
okay something i just noticed
so i just assumed obviously he's hurting
her again yeah yeah and then she was
like gee
i feel my blood pressure dropping what
does that mean
that that's because i've no one's ever
told said that to me before yeah
i don't really know what does that even
feel like i don't know
so obviously you know what my yard looks
like so i'm sitting opposite her on the
dining room on the timetable yeah
um sorry she was like gee
i think my blood pressure's dropping
she's in a chair
and then she closes her eyes and then
her head rocks back
her head rocks back and i'm like g g
g g nah g
mothers g my g james
g i was screaming mothers mothers
mothers i don't forget
i was like gee and she was
non-responsive i was like bella
and i got up and i was shaking her chest
she was
like you know when like you know when
someone's life then you shake it down
they're just like moving as well
so i was pressing their chest pressing
her chest pressing her chest i was like
bella
bella bella like her she
there was a point where i thought she
was coming through because her eyes were
closed but her eyes were rolling
so she could hear me but i don't think
she could feel me oh my god
and she was lifeless in the chat oh my
god james she was lifeless
in the chair for about a minute then
obviously a minute sounds so
short oh no i can imagine it was like 10
hours
james that's terrifying and as soon as
as soon as like
i thought that i genuinely thought she
was dead like i thought like
i have to call an ambulance down yeah
yeah yeah yeah because i thought she was
gone yeah yeah and i was like oh my god
i don't know what to do
i genuinely don't know what to do
because that i felt like
i felt like they would think i had done
something yeah do you know what i mean
because
it just felt so weird yeah it's such a
weird scenario because there was no
explanation yeah
that's not me no explanation and then i
kept on screaming bella bella bell i was
pressing her chest pressing her chest
i was like [ __ ] and there's i screamed
again bella
and then she came through i was like as
soon as she came through
i fell on the floor i bet you [ __ ]
did bro i fell on the floor i went on my
hands and knees and i couldn't breathe
bro
i couldn't i was gasping for air
gasps air shaking i've never
felt such fear such
anxiety such like i couldn't
i couldn't express the feeling because
i've never felt it before yeah yeah she
got up
went to the sofa and just said i'm so
sorry g i'm so sorry and i was like
has this happened before she was like
this has never happened to me in my
entire life
but the way she went about that
transaction as if it was as if it's
happened before
i'm sorry you had to see this but she
said it's never happened before
jesus christ james i was on the floor i
bet you i was on the floor my hands
collapsed my blood would feel cold i
couldn't
breathe oh my god that's certain
have you gone to the daughter no are you
winding me up
no i'm not widening you up i asked i
asked it throughout that night
so it's always not finished okay cool
sorry's not finished go on
so as soon as as soon as i i was on my i
was still on my hands and knees or
whatever
and then when i finally got through i
got up and said oh do you want some
water do you need some sugar
dtc um so i got some i think i've got
some chalk we didn't have any sweets in
the yard we had chocolates and
lucas eight sport so i gave her that
electrolytes get those electrolytes
there's electrolytes in i gave her that
and i gave her some chocolate
and then i i finished my food she
couldn't finish her so we were sat
opposite each other
on the sofas now um
and this this happened
at quarter to 8 p.m
and by 8 20 8 25 pm she was like gee
i'm so tired and i was like bella it's
don't go sleep it's 8 20 whatever
whatever you do please don't go to sleep
because
i don't know if i can handle this yeah
yeah yeah so
but obviously she was trying to fight it
yeah so i she was lying down and i'm
sitting on the other so far
she's she's trying to she's she's
rocking she's rocking but i can see her
legs shaking because she's trying to
fight herself to stop sleeping oh okay
but she that's how tired she is yeah
that's how she and she was like
gee please can you just let me can i
just nap for 10 minutes and you wake me
up
i was like if you're sure okay
because i'm still i'm going to stay here
yeah i mean i'm going to stay i'm not
going in
because i'm [ __ ] petrified um so she
she's still trying to fight herself to
fall asleep so she's she
she's about to go and then she shakes
and wakes up again so this happens like
three four times in the space of
the space of half an hour yeah i'm like
oh my god so i bought more sweets
i was like okay i'm going to get them
from dancing because i ordered them to
come to the yard so i got that
i was like gee i work her rubs like i'm
just going to get these sweets from
downstairs
i was like cool i'm still gonna be here
cool whatever got the sweets
gave her some gave her some and as soon
as she started eating that
she started to feel a bit better and
then she drew for another round of
sweets but she sat up this time
and she's like okay i was like okay i
feel like you're slowly getting back to
yourself
now and then she said to me gee
there was a point where i thought i
wasn't gonna make it this was after the
waking up this is while she was on the
sofa
she was she said to me afterwards like
gee it was a point i thought i wasn't
gonna make it
and but i was too scared to tell you
james if
if you thought your eye ting was bad i
have never
felt such fear in my life
in my entire life why has she not been
to the hospital
i don't i'm confused this needs to be
addressed immediately
i don't know i've told her i've told her
but i don't know
you don't just pass out and then
feel extraordinarily tired and need a
serious influx of sugar
from some weird pain in your stomach and
then just move on with your day
i don't know if the two coincided but
i'm assuming that because she felt the
pain looked at it
i was like gee my blood pressure my
blood pressure's dropping
and then i passed out she just for over
a minute for a minute
she just went that's a long [ __ ] time
bro she just
i i closed my eyes now and think about
it because i'm talking about it now i
can see it happening again it was the
scariest thing that's ever happened to
me
she needs to go to a hospital fast
scariest thing that's happened to me you
know why she needs to go hospital why
you know why this is about to get much
more stressful because when this episode
comes out there's going to be about 90
comments like
from bear doctors and nurses like she's
got this class
she's got seven hours left don't say
that
now that's yeah yeah yeah
well that's terrifying from both sides
from boats fam she said to me gee there
was a point where i thought i wasn't
going to make it
oh she said to me if i thought this was
it but she was too scared
i'm glad she was too scared to tell you
exactly if she had told me that because
there was
during that period we were on the sofa i
was like gee do you need me to call an
ambulance just let me know so i can so i
can just do it yeah
i mean because i didn't want to preempt
and just call it yeah be like no no no
don't call it like
you can't [ __ ] cancel an ambulance
yeah i mean it's not a newborn
they're coming you can't say now they're
imagine
imagine i try to call the police call
999 back and be like
nah cancel it she said she's all right
counselor
they're going to rock up with police fam
because they're going to suspect
something they're going to suspect foul
i was james i was screaming i was
screaming her name
like i can only imagine people that
heard me scream and i couldn't imagine
or can think what's going on in this
yard i was screaming her name
i would have smacked her face i said
wake the [ __ ] and while i was praying
when she woke up and after i was
finished pressing on her chest she was
like she could hear me but she couldn't
feel me
she couldn't feel a thing it's not
normal fam that's not normal
like bearing in mind okay jace here um
bearing in mind
i've never experienced that in my life
like that's that's quite terrifying it's
one of the worst things that happened to
me um
let me go get jay and then we'll do the
[ __ ] yeah cool oh
i'm out of breath boy cool so yeah
am i the [ __ ] i might be [ __ ] gang
all right
one donny sent me one today actually so
we can use that
i'm just lucky cool man right
so
dude oh wait that's not it hang on
where's the
[ __ ] one did it come through i
thought i might come through on the
part no i was just looking my person for
some reason i thought
it was for me there it is
oh it's long oh is it an
hour may is an hour all right cool right
but
listen up team so hey guys love the
podcast etc etc thank you thank you
thank you thank you
um i feel sometimes i struggle with the
i don't know what you call it i know
what you mean like them giving us the
affirmation kind of thing the the
the niceness yeah i was i wouldn't call
it kiss arsenal's because that's
horrible but
i don't know it's not yeah i'm just not
good at compliments that's what i'm
saying i'm not good as i thought that
but thank you
so i'm in a bit of a situation right now
and i'm hoping you guys have some advice
so i'm 16 i live in toronto gang um
i've been talking to a girl on and off
for a few years
i got to know her really well and
started liking her gang we got to the
point
where i spell it wrong but where we were
on a few dates
amir that we liked each other it was all
going well until one day she wasn't in
the mood for my jokes
and went off bringing up a conversation
i had
with one of our mutual friends in which
me and the mutual friend joked about my
relationship with her
being sexual when obviously it wasn't um
she said the conversation made her feel
uncomfortable and like i was just gonna
use her like a fuckboy
and at this point we never talked about
sex and we hadn't had no intention of
bringing it up
so i of course apologized but she wasn't
having it and we haven't spoken since
i reached out to her a few days after
and she ghosted me
so i knew she was mad i wrote her a
letter
jesus brush
i rate the tenacity jesus
we'll come back to that we'll come back
we'll come back you're right in this car
man
uh i wrote her a letter uh and the card
apologizing to her
uh which was funny and i left it on the
doorknob
in case she didn't want to see me uh she
didn't hit me back up but i learned from
the same mutual friend that she read the
letter found it funny good good good
good good good
so i'm still wondering if we're done or
not so it's three weeks later after i
gave the letter
my boys have told me that another girl
who's shooting her shot at me
i think she's really attractive but as
you can tell i'm so hung up about the
girl i was seeing
as we haven't talked since then my
question is
would i be the [ __ ] if i stopped
trying to make it out before i started
dating the other girl who shot her shot
and if so how should i try to talk to
the girl i dated to see if we still have
something
or if my or if i'm clear to start
something with the new girl
thanks again jesus bro
long winded so summary right i'm reading
i've got it open as well
cool so the basic summary is for anyone
who got lost along the way
my guy was dating a girl nothing sexual
would happen they haven't even talked
about anything sexual
they have a mutual friend and whilst he
was chatting to that mutual friend he
just said they were just
[ __ ] non-stop obviously that isn't
true and obviously it was a joke
my girl didn't think it was a joke and
thought that he was just coming
like a [ __ ] boy yeah and just wanted to
just pepper the nine in it
[Music]
playboy so
she's vex and
uh she's locked him off he's apologized
man sending notes pigeons
writing sonnets man's going on
funkypigeon.com
he's about it um but she's still not
having it she read the letter
to giggle um but then let him know that
she'd read it
and now his boys said yo this is next
thing she's down you know
long it's a it's a bit of a maze yeah
cool so um for one
the she's this is the thing with me is i
struggle sometimes
with girls defense like a lot of women
have a big defense mechanism
with thinking that potentially they
could be seen
as just me to man you know what i mean
yeah because like i said like obviously
the reality of the situation is that
he's never [ __ ] her
he's never tried to [ __ ] her they've
never even spoke about [ __ ] yeah he
made a joke about [ __ ] her yeah
and that was enough for her to be like
i'm not about this i'm not about to be
used as
your little play thing because something
tells me there might be more to the
story because it seems a bit
much to just lock someone off entirely
but then again he said he's only 16
anyway so you never know what's going on
the teenage mind
you never know they probably haven't
really got into that that sexual
laughter
yet so she's probably still a virgin
yeah maybe maybe she doesn't want to
yeah i'll let you finish anyway yeah she
don't want to leap to that yeah
um so cool maybe she just thought saw
them as like a
bit a bit deeper than that yeah and
thought that my man's just biding his
time
so he can bust nuts maybe she thought
this is this is fake talk clearly
because you're just out here trying to
[ __ ]
yeah this friendship friendship thing
eight to one um but anyway so
past that there's another thing that's
down so she's airing him aaron america
there's another thing that's down and he
wants to know
if he should have a clear conscience
moving on to the next thing i would say
it's tough i would uh i would i would
say get your closure but she's airing
you
she's average you aired you from
multiple mediums yeah
and you only know that she read the
letter because you home girl told you
she read the letter so she hasn't even
given you the
i don't know i'll probably reach out one
last time and say big man this is the
thing
i care about you cuz this whole this
whole [ __ ] thing is a joke
if you can't take it as a joke then you
clearly don't get my personality and
maybe it won't work anyway if you can
see
how i how it's a joke and maybe we can
move past it that's gang if you're still
interested
um but if not let me know now okay um
and then
your conscience is clear we'll move into
the thing um
but i would also say there's there's no
shortage of [ __ ] in the world cause
so just because your boys said this
thing's down it doesn't mean you have to
leap frog
to the next thing immediately for every
tom dick and harry that's really
yeah yeah that's also a good point yeah
man if if this thing
wasn't on the table initially just
because she's buffing the mandom said
that she's about it doesn't mean that
you have to drop everything in yeah
scurry over there when you're out here
leaving love notes to
to gally there's
anyway say your piece man um so my
the first thing i thought about when he
said oh he said to his boy oh well
we've just been smashing on stop
counting i feel like
i don't know if it's a certain age of
guys or guys in general or some guys in
general
i feel like sometimes guys date girls
just to impress guys oh one million you
know what i mean
one million percent the fact that he
felt it was comfortable to say to his
boy and with this going yes we're just
we've just been [ __ ] when
even though he knows it's not true but
he just did it for an ego complex
so do you think he was potentially being
serious to his brethren
about it but told home girl that he was
joking
no i i think i think obviously him and
his girl or him and his girl at the time
would i'm assuming i'm going to assume
they're virgins i'm just going to assume
off the bank divergence because it's 16
years old i'm just going to assume
they're virgins
so they've not [ __ ] or even if they
have [ __ ] it's just between them he's
not they've not wanted to make that
well he said that they haven't [ __ ]
okay so perfect they've not [ __ ]
so the fact that he's told his boy that
they're just outright [ __ ]
or he's just he's just there for the
puss it's obviously a part on her
because
and how did she find out first and
foremost because it's the mutual so his
brethren that he said it to
yeah is her friend as well so he's an
idiot first of all he's an idiot
but that's what him trying to say is he
knew that they were veterans so maybe it
was a joke that's why i'm thinking maybe
he's right maybe it was a joke
maybe saying the truth maybe it was a
joke or maybe he thought that he was
closer with the mutual then and it did
you know
there's too many tangents in it and i
feel like
at that not necessary at that age but i
don't know i just feel like that's that
was not the
the right move especially because it's
immediate it's not like the person he
told
was far removed from his girl so it
would never go back to his girl so even
if it was a joke
i would have stabbed him to him and his
boy yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't know
i don't know i think that's sticky what
do you think about the [ __ ] thing
about him moving on to next um i don't
i don't think he's an [ __ ] for that i
feel like like you said as well if
we're already getting aired so if you
give it one last hurrah and be like
listen it was a joke etc can we move
past this
if not after you sneezed cuz
if not um yeah let's move on to the next
thing
but within the same roof like you said
as well don't always just because he's
16 i feel like
he's just trying to get this when i was
16 fam i would i would have taken anyone
that would have me
anyone that would have had but yeah you
need to learn
so i can understand the the sentiment
like it's tough out here
it's tough but you've got to learn that
there is enough scene as well
maybe not not now for your age right now
obviously but
it will come you said you want to bring
up the letter thing again yeah man but
as soon as he says i wrote a letter i
was thinking
that's uh that's a different thing but
obviously you didn't finish it because
you said letter in a card
yeah yeah yeah i remember yeah this is
funny
when i was 16. this has happened to me
when i was six
months at 16 i have feelings you know
yes when i was 16
there's a girl i was dating and i found
out
in front of my boy so basically she used
to date a guy
that lived about two or three streets
away from me
okay so she just started driving so i
think she just turned 17
she got her car she i think she did a
crash course thing so literally like
three days after her birthday 17th
birthday she was whipping
yeah yeah so i remember on the day she
whipped me up and we went on a little
drive drive i was just
feeling wonderful hair in the
he's like a air outside the window drop
me back back up my mom's yard i was gas
i skipped back in the yard
so i'm thinking me and this girl in love
yeah
we had to smash nothing i think i gave
her a little stinky and that's it
but she had a man across the way but her
ex-man lived across the way okay
he was older he was like 21 at the time
okay
so me and my boys are walking to
sainsbury's
so they pick me up they they're not for
me walking walking walking and
coincidentally on my way to sainsbury's
is my man's yard
so we're walking okay my boy taps me on
the shoulders like
i swear that's my girl's car and i was
like
i tried to deny it in it and i was like
nah it's not a guy he's a big man
that's her car you can't lie all my boys
are there and i'm like
[ __ ] that's a car cars outside my man's
yard
not even outside his yard in his drive
oh yes she's
and she's in there getting bus open from
getting penetrated
and i was like nah so i remember
what was it like myspace or something
like that
i sent the longest message from and i
was at my pc firm
just bear on there like yo listen i know
what it is i i know what it is in there
obviously you still love my i was
wearing
i was using love willy nilly you still
love my man it's calm
yeah like i see what it is i think you
should like i wish you just told me what
it is like obviously i just got
embarrassed in front of the boys
like um i know this is probably going to
be harder for me than it is for you
i went deep this is going to be harder
for me than it is for you
and i know there's going to be tears
involved at least on my side
this time
these plays are i'm out here playing
seal in the background from and i'm just
tearing my heart out because
i was so upset so as soon as
i remember because from a rose
bro as soon as my man said he left the
letter in the
thing resonated
i know it i know it hurt him when she
said
i'm done with your jokes she said
something i'm done with your [ __ ]
jokes
don't chat to me it's i know the
sentiment
i know it's like so my man just keep
your head up high
do what you're doing fam give it one
last shot and uh if she's not biased
you're not about it trust me
give it six days and you won't give a
[ __ ] anymore literally i slept on it i
didn't care i wish i could remove the
myspace message
but yeah here's what is man but um let's
wrap it up happy
see you guys next week